back to make sure yes we are live
on the universal tube
there was a website whose company's name
was universal tube and they had the
website
youtube just the letter u and uh they
had to get rid of that because they were
getting their servers overloaded for
some reason uh so we're waiting for
people to come on live on youtube if you
don't have clubhouse
uh that's why we're doing what we're
doing because corey and i want to expand
the conversation around what might be a
foundational shift
in the world's economic and financial
and technological structure
and to do that i think it would only be
fair to involve people that don't have
access to clubhouse of which i've heard
there are a few
actually one of my friends who works for
a giant company that is not
allowing their users or for some reason
does not have access for their phone
users
to use a clubhouse which will be named
uh
not named but maybe providing the
infrastructure for the youtube support
that we're enjoying right now
he kind of did something that gave me
hope even though he was a little bit
annoyed that we're
doing a lot on clubhouse he said you're
just a gold
bug and and you just you know only want
to hear about gold
and i said uh that's interesting you
know that means i'm actually doing a
good job because
peter schiff when i did an interview
with peter schiff peter of course said
you know i'm a bitcoin guy and i am so i
am i'm kind of being neutral i always
say
i keep my podcast politically neutral i
keep
uh republicans and democrats and
independents out of it because i always
say
astronomy is a safe space from politics
right there's no republican asteroid
there's no democratic comment
we can all agree on the wonders of the
universe today we are going to be
um sharing a conversation with corey
clipston is that how you pronounce it
corey
yeah you nailed it awesome man i've been
uh
a fan of yours for a while i just made
connection through we tried to host uh
peter schiff on the into the impossible
podcast
do you want to get a check in on on
clubhouse to make sure that we're
sounding okay are we are we sounding
okay camille
give us up yourself on clubhouse and i
will stream
through my audio on youtube okay you
want me to mute myself
sure yes please okay great okay we are
all set up we've now got there we go
a whole bunch of people on youtube a
bunch of thumbs up
uh thanks to my fans i'm introducing uh
so yeah the trick is just plug in some
uh some headphones or something
and turn the volume down that works good
yeah except that won't be able to charge
it
otherwise you only give us one yeah they
only give us one option here
uh so let's see i could do one or you
can just turn it way down and put your
phone far away from you that way yeah
that's what i'm doing now yeah that's
right i'll do that
and uh so we're gonna take questions uh
later on from clubhouse
and uh even from the youtube channel so
i'm going to monitor my youtube channel
dr brian keating
for those of you that want to see us
live
conversing and we will also have a
live stream where we'll take questions
and comments as
corey normally does he's one of the most
active if not the most active
uh clubhouse user in this space along
with a lot of um
friends and compatriots in the bitcoin
space
so i want to first start corey because i
thought it would be wonderful
to do a debate to do a conversation
between peter schiff
and michael saylor and so i've had both
gentlemen on my podcast
both bring as you know diametrically
opposed views
and i as i said earlier i keep getting
kind of uh pigeonholed as being
you know a gold bug or a bitcoin bug i
don't know are there such things i know
they're hobblers but uh
do you call yourself a bitcoin bug is
that we just we just call them
bitcoiners
bitcoiners yeah actually so uh so i got
accused of both
man i said well let's bring them both
together i'll be impartial
and uh and i secretly extended an invite
to michael saylor
and he politely declined and then peter
shifts folks i don't know peter's on
clubhouse is anyone on clubhouse
monitoring to see if peter schiff is
there he is a follower of mine
uh peter schiff then basically used the
fact that michael didn't debate him
as evidence that michael's scared to
debate or whatever and i said
i don't think that that's a fair
assessment even from a scientific point
of view
to assume that someone not wanting to
debate you
is a sign of as a sign of fear
cowardice or whatever leave that aside
for one second
then i also uh wanted to remind people
that corey
uh tuned in to my live chat when i got
peter schiff on clubhouse for his first
appearance
and uh and it sounded like to the
uninitiated
that peter was just talking over corey
and not letting him answer and
maybe insulting him and he may have been
doing that corey
but part of the blame lies in my lack of
clubhouse technological sophistication
and not being able to take questions
except for holding them up to the
microphone so now we have a much better
setup and now we're going to let
corey really take it away and i asked
corey
if we could have a a kind of
conversation from his perspective
another precious metal is steel and
sometimes what we want to do is
form steel man arguments to understand
better
where our opponents might be coming from
because it helps sharpen
our own arguments so corey for my
audience could you introduce yourself
your background and um and and give us
an introduction to what you do
yeah absolutely so corey klipsten
founder and ceo of swanbitcoin.com
um which is basically like a retail
focus sort of uh
first place to buy bitcoin learn about
bitcoin in the united states
and then we also have uh swan private
client services which is
an international service uh for high net
worth individuals and
uh and companies around the globe uh to
buy bitcoin
and um i guess kind of a long career
in uh in tech and uh management
consulting and finance worked for
microsoft and google
mckenzie morgan stanley university of
chicago mba
finance and entrepreneurship long long
time ago and um
got into startups while i was at google
in 2011 to 2013
started mentoring startups and ended up
moving to the west coast
and uh been in startup land full-time
since summer of 13. so about eight years
now
i'm involved in 40-something startups as
an advisor investor former operator
um and fell down the bitcoin rabbit hole
starting in early 2017 with the price
run up and
uh had it completely uh backwards
thinking of it
from a tech perspective because all the
people that i respected in technology
basically had it wrong whether it was
andreas and horowitz or
union square ventures or you know sort
of all these tech people up in sf
thinking that you know this was much
more about tech than it was about money
they knew it was a bit of money but i
think it was kind of like they thought
it was 80
tech 20 money and it's actually more
like the reverse it's like 80 to 90
money in like 10 or 20 tech um
and so it took me about 11 months to get
through
what we generously call the altcoin
horseshoe
starting with bitcoin exploring
everything else and then coming back to
bitcoin and
and what was really interesting about
that journey for me is just how much i
relied on the
incredible educators that started coming
into the space in 2017-2018 so
you know if you're new to bitcoin over
the last couple years and you think that
you know well safe dean's book was
always around and there was always a
stephan lavera podcast or uh tales from
the crypt podcast and
you know brady swenson doing citizen
bitcoin like these things didn't
exist jan pritzker's book came out in
spring of or summer of 2019 like a lot
of these things that are
passed around that are just touchstones
for bitcoin education didn't exist
before
and i was really inspired by that and
you know i think the um
the main thing that i say over and over
again that i've been saying for a few
years now is that uh
you know the uh the amount of
wealth that someone is willing to store
in the bitcoin
protocol is highly correlated with their
understanding of bitcoin
and so that kind of led me to think like
the way to sell bitcoin is really just
to educate people about bitcoin and help
them
you know ramp up their understanding and
then they would want to buy a lot
more so this company was founded on
that thesis that you could essentially
just create
a media house or a publisher or
something that was putting out tons of
bitcoin content
and helping other people but put out
bitcoin content newsletters podcasts
videos etc
produce some of your own content provide
the back end for other people's content
sponsor lots of content and uh and
basically just get the education
up leveled and increase it and then
if you had bitcoin for sale as part of
that then you'd probably do pretty well
so that's how we have built the company
coming up on a year we launched uh at
the end of march of 2020
uh for for swanbitcoin.com and uh it's
been great
and uh we'll probably start sharing some
numbers uh
probably in q2 but holding off just for
now but we're a team of about 20 people
and a lot of great bitcoiners working on
this people like gigi
you guys probably know from 21 lessons
uh jan pritzker author of inventing
bitcoin brady swenson
brandon quittim brackyvon bitcoin
camilla campton
uh on and on reed womack and a bunch of
other writers and producers it turns out
they all have other skills too
like they uh they either code or they've
done seo
or they can write and uh so we kind of
just figure out what bitcoiners
can do other than just talk about
bitcoin on twitter and hire them
there's more to doing uh bitcoin than
just talking on twitter i seem to
relish in my uh my my feed now is now
populated by
again saying i'm a shell for one side or
another which to me means i'm doing my
job of being impartial
but you know of course we don't want
just committee for committee's sake not
comedy we'll always take comma d but
comma t
but one thing i really respect about you
corey and going over your
your work is that you are an educator
you obviously have some interest
obviously
but you are impartial and as evidenced
by the fact you come on the end of the
impossible podcast
to talk about sort of the bear case the
steel man case against your own point of
view
and i have a lot of respect for that
because i don't know if somebody like
peter schiff again i'm not sure if he's
in clubhouse
if he is i don't mind saying this to him
i don't know if he can do it and i don't
know if he can take the opposite point
of view
for a variety of reasons as i said i
don't blame him
for you know talking over you because
that was just awkward the technological
limitations that we had although as i
said he might talk over you
if we were in person and knowing him
he's uh he's gotten a lot of hate mail
etc
but what i like is that you are capable
of doing this
and you've taken on a role which i think
is really important normally i don't
know if you've watched any of my past
episodes i usually interview
you know nobel prize winners and uh and
authors and so forth and whenever i get
an author on the phone or on the
on the zoom as is more likely i always
ask him or her
to ignore the advice that people give
you to not
judge a book by its cover i say no i
judge books by their cover all the time
in fact the publishing industry is
predicated on that i want to know where
did you come up with the
name swan bitcoin what does that have to
do is that a black swan reference
what does that refer to yeah it is it is
a black swan reference
um i i became a huge fan of uh
mrs m telev's work starting in was 2002
i think was when uh malcolm gladwell had
the first article
about tele called uh blowing up in the
new yorker which uh was about the same
time that he put out his first
uh sort of widely available book
followed by randomness
and uh you know blowing up was about him
about tele taking the opposite side of
most of long-term capital management's
trades
uh or at least batting against the
trades that they had on basically and it
was just this whole idea that life is a
call option
uh and that there are free call options
all around free or cheap call options
all around
and that if you understand how to
take actions that limit your downside
and give you unbounded upside
and you don't even need to be right very
often you can be right you know
a tenth of the time or even a hundredth
of the time if the payoff
from the times that you're right is so
much larger
than uh the times that you lose so you
know i think in
in film you saw this with uh you know
michael bury in the big short
you know bleeding money for his
investors every month as he had these
big insurance contracts out but then
there's a huge payoff when he's proven
right
so that's kind of what that's about and
then the black swan came out in uh i
want to say 2006
and uh was just you know exploded into
popular culture
uh i bought a copy of it for my roommate
at the time who was a mid-senior guy on
the distress bank loan
sales desk at goldman and he proceeded
to buy copies for his entire desk which
is kind of a funny
story um i don't know that maybe helped
them get short
subprime before the crash it's possible
um
but yeah and then bitcoin came along and
obviously i you know the white paper was
published
nine years before i really went down the
rabbit hole i made the mistake of
ignoring it when somebody gave me some
in 2014.
but for me you know a lot of people
think black swans can only be negative
but really it's just any
outside outsized event that is
uh not forecast by very many people and
that has a major
impact right and that can be positive or
negative and so i see bitcoin
as being the largest positive black swan
uh potentially in history but certainly
for many many
decades probably many centuries so that
was kind of the thesis there
and then once we started hiring more
people you know they have their own
views on
what it might mean and yan and some of
the other folks are pretty partial to
the idea that bitcoin
at inception you know in the dark net
days and mountain gox and all of that
was maybe a bit of an ugly duckling
and now it's uh this beautiful white
swan that's taking flight so it kind of
works in that way as well
of course you know one of the celebs
claims in that
apocalype book is that after a black
swan event occurs
people say oh in retrospect it was
obvious um and and that we should have
known better
but of course you know there is that
hindsight is 2020
but as a risk management tool i want to
know
from your perspective how did you handle
risk management prior to bitcoin
and is bitcoin the essential the
sui generis is there any other
alternative and
we have bitcoin tina in the audience
probably but is there an alternative in
terms of
risk mitigation and hedging that could
be useful
or is it basically bitcoin tina
um yeah you're making reference to there
is no alternative which is a
great acronym used by our friend on
clubhouse and youtube shows
um
there's no other asset in the world
widely available with a better risk
reward
profile than bitcoin so in that respect
if you're looking for
that thing with the best sharpe ratio or
that thing that lives on the efficient
frontier to kind of push out the total
return of your portfolio
or the total expected return of your
portfolio while reducing that risk
uh there's nothing better than bitcoin
and there's never been anything better
than bitcoin so
yeah in that respect that's true uh
it's also true that it has uh you know
high volatility versus
you know you know properly constructed
portfolios that may be more about wealth
preservation or just make sure
that you know you're just not
comfortable writing it up writing it
down
every few years or whatever form these
these bitcoin bowl and bear markets take
in the future
um you know so i'm not sitting here
saying that every single person with
you know a billion dollars should be 100
bitcoin like
there are all kinds of reasons that
people may choose
because of investment horizons or just
like over
you know just being averted to having
that much volatility
um but over time you know we expect that
volatility will reduce as market cap
increases those things should be uh
you know inversely correlated so i think
as you get in you know five ten years
out from now you'll be looking at a much
much higher market cap and you'll be
looking at much
lower volatility we've already seen that
you know
volatility in pretty much any time frame
you know one
day 60 day one year whatever reduces
significantly
over time with bitcoin
and when i had a conversation with
michael saylor of course he's obviously
a
very prominent bullish uh advocate a
relatively recent convert much more
recently than you
and he's gotten a lot of attention and i
think a lot of flak
and it surprises me just parenthetically
that peter gets away with basically
accusing him of running a con
job to suggest an uncorrelated asset
could have a place in the portfolio of
many people
but before we get into that i do want to
sort of start down this rabbit hole of
you know talking about the intrinsic
merit of this and i'll take the
side of the um of the bitcoin
bull uh while you take the bearer side
and we'll kind of see how that goes but
before we do that i did feel uh and i'm
just reminding my audience
on the into the possible podcast on
youtube on itunes etc
dr brian keating on youtube technically
we're talking with corey
clipston who who is the founder director
of swanbitcoin.com
but also you have a youtube channel too
that's pretty much thriving
in these times what's the name of that
uh corey again
yeah it's uh youtube.com swan signal
it's one signal and um
swan signal yes you just type in swan
signal in the search it'll pop up
and uh yeah we do a pretty serious
tuesday show where we generally pair
you know two pretty prominent bitcoiners
or sort of macro investing types
uh and that's that's live every tuesday
and it's also a podcast it's one of the
top ranked uh bitcoin podcasts and
charging up the tech charts as well
which is pretty cool
uh and then friday is our more casual
show it's called swan lounge
um and that one usually is just a bunch
of bitcoiners kind of hanging out and
talking about the news of the day and
sharing bullish price forecasts and and
ripping on no coiners like peter chef
well he makes himself a very fat plump
target for most of this but one thing
you know when i talk to michael
i am a scientist i'm an astrophysicist
and when i would talk to him you know i
would make this case
that is actually going to be a bullish
case
for the dollar and i want to make this a
statement uh
and before we put on the steel manning
etc that the
you know the number one fear of the
united states government is true it's
probably deflation
that they're going to do whatever it
takes to you know keep their heads off
the guillotine
probably including printing unlimited
amounts of money and we've heard
statements that neil kashkari has said
that they have an infinite amount of
dollars i didn't know there was anything
in physics
certainly is not known to be anything
that's infinite except as albert
einstein said
the universe and human stupidity
although i'm not so sure
about the universe and he ultimately was
right about that
but i want to make the bullish case in
the dollar okay so the dollar
is is a very special entity it is the
reserve currency it is fiat that's true
uh however uh it has a certain type of
of
uh essence of proof of work and that
proof of work
as i said to michael saylor goes by the
name of nine
u.s nuclear-powered battle groups
aircraft carrier battle groups
each one of which is worth about a
trillion dollars all in if you include
all the aircraft the battleships etc the
or the
destroyers and the aircraft carriers
including all that
that's an awful lot of work that went
into
generating those we own uh you know we
have 90 percent of the military spending
on earth
we have an incredible influence on the
world every country on earth
has positive associations net positive
of course there's net negative people
think negatively of the us i'm sure
but more people want to come here than
anywhere else it's only increasing the
us passport is incredibly valuable
people die for it kill for it etc
there's a tremendous amount of stored
value and uh and i would say to peter
schiff i would say the same thing i'd
say to
michael saylor and i am saying it to you
there is an awful lot of work that went
into the accumulation of wealth in the
united states
and i to say that it was going to you
know go to the moon or go to zero rather
i find that a little bit hard to swallow
so where am i wrong
in that argument well you're thinking
about the medium of exchange the dollar
actually being the capital
the accumulated capital so it doesn't
really matter what you measure
the value of those aircraft carriers and
all the built-up capital and buildings
and factories
and you know the the knowledge base in
silicon valley and
you know mit stanford new york wherever
it may be
the entertainment capitals of la and
atlanta like you know it doesn't
it doesn't matter what that's
denominated in um so i think that's
probably the first thing
you won't find me saying i mean where we
would agree
uh and this would go like for any of the
stratfor
like peter zion types or or the case
that you're making
i absolutely agree there's like no
chance that another fiat currency
is going to usurp the dollar's place as
uh
the reserve asset there's zero chance
for the euro zero chance for the yuan
nothing else is close like we're it's
the dollar unless until
it's bitcoin
and um sorry i'm just you caught me at
coffee
so this is interesting right so uh it's
not
bitcoin is so in line with the
principles
of the founders of the united states of
america it's actually like the perfect
money for
like renaissance ideals enlightenment
ideals for the ideals embodied in the
constitution
in the bill of rights etc i mean it
really you have to remember like we
didn't have the fed printing endless
dollars
until like 1913 there was 100 years
there we you know basically were
fairly responsible there was a lot of
free banking it was essentially a global
gold standard for most of the second
half of the
19th century and you know everything
kind of
flourished there was obviously like all
kinds of
you know bad things at local levels and
not everybody benefited equally or
whatever but you know you had uh
oil increasing productivity by 10 000 x
for factories
and moving off of you know having to go
hunt whales and things like that you had
electricity
come to the fore you had you know soap
and vaccines and all these things you
know in the early 20th century
um you know that were kind of completed
and so we all saw this amazing
advancement and the other thing that
happened is you know basically from like
1800 to 1900
uh things cost less a hundred years
later
um so you essentially did have mild
deflation uh over that hundred years
at the same time as having all this
incredible advancement so
one thing that's just false is that the
you know whatever you think of the
united states and let's just call it
some level of greatness or uniqueness or
whatever
that that hinges on having uh the
reserve currency is provably false it's
empirically false
it's a tool and as with other previous
empires that have had the global reserve
currency
initially it's a great thing you
basically can export paper
or whatever you're you know you can just
print money and you can get goods and
services
but in the later stages of your empire
and your
your status as being the reserve
currency you face the triffin dilemma
which anybody can google and get into
basically it's that essentially you rot
out your manufacturing base
and uh you're essentially kind of just
rot from the inside
as an empire that has the the global
reserve currency
so i'm actually really looking forward
to a day
when we don't have the reserve currency
when we're on an equal
you know a level playing field and the
natural advantages of which there are
many
for the united states and i could just
take off like some of the big ones
but you know things like having uh more
mileage of navigable waterways connected
to
productive farmland than the rest of the
world combined the us has about thirteen
thousand miles the rest of the world has
about twelve thousand miles
of navigate waterways so it's like the
whole breadbasket
the interna the interior former uh
sea from the old days that you know
empties into the gulf of mexico for
instance is
just uh all arable land basically
connected to uh to deep rivers that go
to the ocean so
things like that things like being you
know protected on the on the left and
the right west and east
um you know and not having to fight wars
nobody can come and like invade you from
over the pacific or the atlantic you
know it's really difficult to do
something like that so
you know entrepreneurial spirit and kind
of the the the base level of society
that's been created by
uh by the constitution and the checks
and balances like so there is a lot of
social and political advantage there
kind of the entrepreneurial spirit the
frontier spirit that's lasted for
hundreds of years i mean it's
not that long ago that you know santa
monica had like 50 000 people
and no water you know and now it's
slowly it'll turn into like hong kong on
the beach over time you know and uh
people forget how young this country is
and uh
and i think a lot of these things like
we ebb and flow and new york goes
bankrupt in the 70s and we
have bouts of populism but you know by
and large it reverts to the mean
and there are so many geographic and
demographic
and socio-political advantages to to
this place
that having good money i think only
increases
the advantages of the united states oh
yeah i see it as a hopeful sign right
people talk about it as if it's you know
doomsday prepping and that's all it's
good for and
of course you have to admit i talk to a
lot of people that search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and those
people
also suffer from the fact that many
people who want to believe in
alien activity of being real also
believe that aliens are walking around
with prosthetic foreheads and
and so forth so there are people that
are correlated with the bitcoin
narrative
that may be that kind of doomsday
scenario
and almost anticipating it in some sense
but fundamentally i think that bitcoin
represents a type of freedom and we have
so
yes it's true we are founded we are the
oldest democracy right
and uh but but actually we have very few
rights
you know that are pure undiluted on
unmolested so to speak and i think
you know the the aspect of freedom is
actually where we can go out jump off to
because on the on the bear side for
bitcoin
one of the things that we talk about all
the time and i talked about this with
michael
is uh the biggest threat you know being
maybe our own government
who may not like us to have so much
freedom with where we spend our money
and accuse people like yourself or
others of wanting bitcoin because it's
usefulness
at its base layer could be traced to
black market nefarious activity so
let's talk start there uh i don't know
if you have a you know kind of a
a plan of of addressing things but i'm
very interested to know in this
how do we know that as with gold and i
brought this up to peter
it's not like gold hasn't been
confiscated by the us government anyway
oh that wasn't really
they didn't come to your house with guns
they probably would have you know you
would have gotten a lot of trouble yeah
they didn't come to your house and take
all your alcohol either
but you know i'm sure there are local
politicians as we've all learned that
would be all too happy to
put people that are using uh gold back
then or bitcoin now so
dispel that rumor or that myth if it is
a myth maybe it's not
that bitcoin um you know has an
existential threat
from right here in the good old usa so
is the question here would the
government
or which is made up of normal people and
humans that can read and
decide things on their own uh would the
government
decide to essentially do the boots on
next thing and go door to door and try
to extract
not even bitcoin bitcoin private keys
from people's heads
no no not not that but there would be a
windfall because you agree that
in order to do something with bitcoin
one of our listeners is saying he's at a
coffee shop now that accepts bitcoin but
it takes five to ten minutes to process
the block
um so you have to convert it maybe you
don't but but a lot of case you have to
convert it and they could do what they
did in the 70s and 80s with
oil speculators and declare a windfall
profit tax because
yeah you know that is we gotta we gotta
we gotta level you up so you can very
quickly decide not to put
uh idiotic things like that and leave
them up on your youtube channel
um for too long um so i will address
that very quickly since you bothered
leaving it up for a while but
there's no such thing as like immediate
final settlement for dollars either so
if you pay for something with cash app
or with visa or whatever
obviously that's just an entry on an
internal ledger and they're extending
you credit basically
and they have your information
you get a 1099 for it so i'm talking
about paying in dollars
hanging dollars at the coffee shop with
a credit card i'm just saying
that yeah go ahead what i'm saying is
you're going to pay for that at the end
of the month right
um it's not final settlement like
immediately
and so saying that bitcoin you know
you don't need to use the base chain you
can pay with lightning network and
settle that up later with non-chain set
uh transaction you can also just swap
out dollars euros yen or whatever
and use you know as you've seen with
mastercard and visas plans
internationally
adopting you know their plans to adopt
cryptocurrency is as
as payments you can just swap out the
symbol and just run an internal ledger
using bitcoin and just settle up every
now and again between large companies
um so this whole idea of like bitcoin
being used for coffee that's not really
what it's for
i'm just saying somebody is on youtube
saying that he's purchasing i'm not
going to dispute what he said yeah
i wouldn't do that it's silly i wouldn't
bother with that yeah but that no reason
to use on-chain bitcoin to buy coffee
bitcoin is for buying coffee plantations
not coffee okay
but at least on on-chain bitcoin on
chain bitcoin
okay so the difference uh that you're
saying
not to worry uh in that i have sold you
know my microscopic
uh satoshi one satoshi and immediately i
got you know is in the end of 2020
i sold a satoshi or two and i i
you know a day or two later here's a
cash app or whatever and then here's
your 1099
and i was like well what if it was like
a lot of money and what if the
government weren't so friendly
and declared that this is some special
windfall that has happened in the case
of what
is called speculation and if it's not a
currency as
as i think i agree um then it is an
investment or it is subject to capital
gains and
why would it not be appropriate publish
the rules they publish the rules in
advance
and it's a very important part of our
system at least in this country
that you can't change the rules after
the fact well actually sorry corey i
can't i can't let that slip i actually
did get taxed in the state of california
as i assume you did
in 2012 the state legislature put into
effect a tax that was retroactive
and i felt that was unconstitutional but
apparently you had to have a lot of
people dispute that at the state level
at the state level yeah yeah i mean that
is that is
like the worst kind of government i
wasn't here at the time
okay i don't know what that was but uh
yeah i mean you should have gotten
you should have marshaled all your
resources for a bunch of uh pro bono
constitutional law professors to come
and
and write against something like that
because it's absolutely idiotic to do
something like that
i agree against fair law anyway
i mean this this uh it's treated right
now as a as a
you know a capital asset basically just
like any other investment and so just
like
you know if stocks go up or bitcoin goes
up and you sell it
then you're gonna pay short-term capital
gains tax if it's uh you know within
uh the first year or long-term capital
gains
uh if it's after 12 months so that's
just how it works right now so again
it's so early in the development of
bitcoin on its path
to monetization we're basically in that
store value stage and really it's early
in the store value stage still
um and then it'll move into being a much
more widely used medium of exchange and
then
eventually i'd expect in kind of the
15-ish year
range something like that to be a very
widely used
unit of account as well so those are the
kind of the three
stages of monetization of a new asset
so just remind my listeners on youtube
there's over 100 people on different
channels facebook
youtube periscope twitch i think i'm on
twitch
corey you'll be very proud of my
technological acumen
uh we are on clubhouse as well uh with
the uh very well known
corey clipston who is uh going to break
down
the scenario which i originally thought
was stood for food
but i think of everything in terms of
food corey but it's actually fud
uh fear uncertainty and doubt so those
are the three prongs of the triton that
is used to secure
uh bitcoin advocates can you walk us
through each one of those what is the
steel man argument
against bitcoin in those three different
axes or dimensions as we say in physics
um i mean that's really just like a
bucket term for anything that's sort of
like an anti-bitcoin argument
and uh going back to uh peter's
uh brief and and fiery appearance on
your on clubhouse on your show last time
uh what was interesting is it was kind
of a compendium
of all the greatest hits all of which
have been dispelled
uh from the last 10 years or so it was
kind of almost everything that's ever
been said
uh negative about bitcoin and every sort
of worry that somebody's ever come up
with
it was kind of funny because um gigi
on on twitter dirgi d-e-r-g-i-g-i
uh so if you search him and peter chef
you'll find it uh actually
typed furiously and did a big tweet
storm of
basically everything that that peter
said um so i don't know i mean i
i actually expected you to trot them out
but i can try to remember
you know some of the things that people
say about bitcoin
um so you've obviously got the one we
just addressed which
is you know kind of the uh the be cash
crowd that's kind of confused about what
money actually is and the fact that you
can't be a medium of exchange without it
actually having value
and it can't actually have value unless
you have you know
in the long term nothing will have value
unless it actually has that proof of
work
and actually has that decentralization
and you know historically the only money
that's been
adopted in that fashion was gold and now
we have something that's better than
gold
and fiat never has succeeded like the
the longest running fiat currencies have
been you know max like 900 years and
we're probably near the end of of the
dollar's usefulness
as a store of value even though it's
still being used as a medium of exchange
everybody's sort of running from it and
all the smartest investors say cash is
trash
and essentially try to just keep like as
little dollars on hand as possible it's
just working capital for paying
immediate bills
and everything else should be in in some
other asset that doesn't waste away
so that's why we need uh a better money
and sound money
try to think of uh other things that
people say like you know the
government's gonna shut it down well the
government can't shut down
the bitcoin network uh they could
actually shut down the internet
a lot easier than they could shut down
bitcoin because bitcoin is actually a
ledger
and essentially as soon as computers
were reconnected then
people would just reload the ledger and
you'd be off and running again so
only if you shut off the internet
forever and shut off
always in mesh networks and satellite
communications
or people using smoke signals or passing
notes to each other
you know human ingenuity in the face of
trna and oppression is is pretty
spectacular to behold
and as long as there's a copy of the
ledger and as long as there's a shelling
point around people believing that that
really is the ledger that
um is the fair and correct way
to uh keep track of uh the wealth
of people and companies around the world
then you'll always have bitcoin it's
really uh
unkillable um what they may say is like
yeah you could make it really difficult
on a country by country basis
or jurisdiction each jurisdiction could
do something nasty like shut down
exchanges or make it really difficult or
tax gains heavily or whatever it is
um that's not really how the game theory
uh
plays out uh if you do things
contra massive contra
basically against technological
developments that are spectacular like
what bitcoin is
you fall behind very quickly you have a
competitive disadvantage versus all of
the other countries and jurisdictions
that adopt the new technology
and so it's really you know it's the
smart countries that are forward
thinking
that are moving very quickly to adopt
bitcoin and realizing
you know each each person in each
company realizing
individually oh wow this thing has legs
i want to place a bet here
i want to make some money here now you
see all the banks coming in well who
pays for the politicians
the banks right and you know do you
think that coinbase with their 100
billion dollar
uh direct listing in a couple of months
isn't going to have lobbyists
do you think that you know jp morgan
who's banking all of the big crypto
companies now
isn't going to have lawyers isn't going
to make first amendment arguments about
bitcoin just being
free speech like there's it's too far
gone the train left the station so long
ago
in the west at least we'll see what
happens and then we see that
india has tried yet again to ban bitcoin
what's gonna happen there is the same
thing that's happening in nigeria
nigeria banned bitcoin
everybody's still using bitcoin and it's
trading at a 40
premium it's proving that you know their
fiat currency their local fiat currency
is basically worthless
which is exactly what's going to happen
in india as well and then they'll be
forced to
capitulate and come back in as china has
you know three or four times already
so uh china brings me to another topic
that brings up fear
and that is the so-called threat of a
51 attack um i've heard about this
i'm sure you are far more alerted about
it than i am
but uh but walk us through that scenario
as a potential
steel man against bitcoin not for gold
i'm not talking about fiat
gold pork yeah don't care much about
gold but uh
yeah i mean i'm probably not the right
person to get into like the deep
technicals but at the end of the day
uh a lot of people have this
misconception that a 51 attack which is
essentially having like
unfriendly or dishonest uh you know
nodes
uh basically blocking transactions that
people want to put through or
trying to roll back the chain it's
something that uh
that has to be sustained over a very
very long
period of time and costs an immense
amount of power
to do that so we know we know how costly
it is
to run this bitcoin super computing
network around the world that's 100
times more powerful than any other
computing network and to
be able to roll back transactions and
really like affect
confidence in the chain costs so much
money
to do that and it it really doesn't make
any sense because you'd make so much
more money
like the economic incentive is really
just to participate as a good actor and
use all that hash power to earn bitcoins
rather than
trying to kill the network so there's a
game theory thing there there's an
exorbitant cost thing there there is uh
you know the lead time of being able to
get a hold of enough asics
application specific integrated chips so
these these uh bitcoin
these computers that are only good for
one task which is mining bitcoin
to be able to amass enough of those
without everyone else in the world
noticing that that's happening
and that then driving up the price of
bitcoin and making your attack
spectacularly more expensive it just is
not something that you need to worry
about
whatsoever and
in terms of other arguments that go
around uh
frequently this notion obviously yes of
of other countries doing it but i've
never felt that was a
very persuasive argument because unless
all 175 countries around the earth
do it you'd always be able to find a
place where money goes where it's
treated best right that's the old
expression
um my other question you know revolves
around this
debate that and again i'm not peter's
not here maybe he is i haven't checked
clubhouse a
reminder we're talking to corey clipston
who needs no introduction
on clubhouse certainly or on um on
youtube but to my audience and the into
the impossible podcast
we are welcoming him to talk about
basically a response
to some of the discussions that we had
with peter schiff a week or so ago
and peter schiff as you may have noticed
got the attention of elon musk
recently and they had a very active
twitter exchange i actually had my video
producer
put together a uh kind of compendium of
these tweet storms between elon
and peter and i actually offered to
moderate because i was the first person
to get peter on clubhouse
and here he is with the hutzpah to ask
elon musk to be on clubhouse without me
being there
so anyway i said peter you know you
should really let me do it
but i listened to the i watched the uh
the tweet storms back and forth and
really revolved around this this kind of
concept that peter calls the
the digital token can you explain that
aspect of things that this is basically
vaporware it's sure it takes a lot of
energy
and then peter was saying last week as
if he's a huge environmentalist oh it's
really bad for the environment to spend
all this money on
energy let's ignore that but let's just
say
it it takes a lot of energy so what you
know second law of thermodynamics
you know it says we we can't even quit
the game you always lose and you can't
even win
and you have to stay in the game forever
but i want to ask you
what is actually the response to that
argument the digital token you're
collecting these digital beanie babies
but worse because
baby babies actually are made of beans i
don't know
uh how do you attack that structure i
think what i think what that argument
supposedly is about is uh
is intrinsic value and peter claiming
that you know there's this large amount
of intrinsic value
in gold and which really
if you actually look at the history of
money and how it actually develops
gold was chosen for money because it
actually had
characteristics that were good for money
it actually is
uh you know it's it's scarce has a low
stock to flow ratio
uh it's hard to find more of it um it is
uh
you know it is divisible enough where
you can kind of like like slice it up
it's durable
um it's one of the most stable elements
in the periodic table et cetera et
cetera so there's like you know five or
six
characteristics of money 14 if you uh
listen to andy edstern maybe five or six
if you listen to uh
safety and a robert breedlove and um you
know gold rates very highly on those and
that's why it was adopted as money
and its adoption as money was why
it was adopted as jewelry and it's why
we think of gold as like you know good
as gold and this sort of show of wealth
so that uh that correlation i should say
they have the causation backwards uh
people that think that you know because
it's jewelry is why it has value it's
it's actually it's because it's it's
been used as money for so many thousands
of years is the reason that people use
it for jewelry because they want to
show off their wealth on their wrists
and on their necks etc
so that might be the first thing and
then the second thing is the idea that
some
that money would actually want to have
uh
you know productive value or intrinsic
value
uh you know is actually false and it's
only because
you know we didn't have something like
bitcoin previously that
uh that that fallacy is it has taken so
long to be laid bare so now we actually
understand
that something with a 100 of its value
actually
being the monetary premium uh is
is actually better because you're not
crowding out productive use
and what you can see with uh all these
other commodities over the years that
have been
you know attempted to be uh you know
that people tried to use for money
is uh you know you're competing you're
basically competing with productive use
when you want to use it for money
and if you actually have a better money
you might as well just use those things
you know for
filling teeth or for circuits or
whatever it is but essentially
the 90 plus percent maybe more maybe 95
98
of gold's value that is the store value
premium on top of its
productive use essentially will go away
over the next few decades as
uh bitcoin soaks it all up
and when we uh think about the
comparison of bitcoin not only to gold
i think it is fair to talk about other
coins that are out there people are
asking
in the chat room on youtube uh
of course there are you know kind of uh
uh shall we say frivolous coins
that have come up and there are other
coins that are not so frivolous that
have a huge market cap so i'm thinking
in particular of ether
which i know you said you don't want to
discuss in great detail because
of your well you can describe why you
don't want to talk about those too much
no we can we can talk about it a little
bit okay let's go for it so i think they
actually have some interesting features
the little i know about them i'm not a
big
investor in them but i actually think
there are some things that peter didn't
understand
and and if you recall from my debate
with him i kept asking him like
peter you can't hand me a triangle like
a triangle doesn't exist it exists in
the human mind so therefore it has no
physical
value it has no actual tangible visceral
behavior however we all know what a
triangle is there are other things that
have no
um that have no materialistic
association
uh but are worth a lot of money and in
fact there's trillions of dollars
invested around this around the world i
gave the example of escrow
hand me escrow you can't hand me escrow
it's a contract it's some sort of
way of mutually assuring transactions
take place
i find that aspect of some of the
alternatives as i understand
ethereum is capable of that or was
predicated on that in some sense
and it has a huge market cap um what's
wrong with that um
and besides just that bitcoin is better
i don't think that's an actual germain
argument because
there may be other purposes just as
bitcoin has a purpose
and gold has a purpose you're not
denying that you're just saying bitcoin
is superior so besides the fact that
bitcoin is superior to ether
or doge or whatever what are the virtues
and vices of these alternatives sure
well you know just to put a nail in the
argument on gold like
gold has a use in industry
and it has a use it may be like as
bitcoin tina likes to say like they'll
be trinkets because it is shiny it is
cute but those things will cost
you know like children's toys in the
future um what will go away is that
store value premium and that monetary
premium for the asset
um so the altcoins the 10
000 coins that have come and gone uh the
coins that make up
the uh the rest of the pie when you look
at a stat like bitcoin dominance
um so i i do want to make a point there
which is that
uh there's survivorship bias
in the crypto space that includes
majority bitcoin and then
call it you know depending on where you
are in the market cycle you know 20 to
40
altcoins uh as far as total market cap
and basically what it is is almost all
the coins from 2013 are gone
and most of the coins from 2017 are gone
and in 2025 most of the coins from 2021
will be gone
and essentially what these are are
basically affinity marketing scams
or schemes trying to get some of the
heat and some of the shine from what's
going on with bitcoin which is a true
proven innovation that's actually doing
exactly what it purported to do and has
been doing since network launch on
january 3rd 2009
whereas not a single other token is
actually
performing in a truly decentralized
you know capable of withstanding you
know state intervention
you can take down any of these very very
easily
they can be turned off by their
management teams they can be taken out
by a government
action you can't do that to bitcoin
bitcoin is actually decentralized but
aren't they
that's kind of like fail and that's ends
corey aren't they like who's going to
care about
you know something that has marketing up
of 800 million you know if they've been
selling unregistered securities which
you know by the howie definition they
all were sec has already indicated that
you know at least at time of sale
ethereum was
a security and that's kind of obvious if
you look at the look at the law
they've kind of been given sort of a
pass not actually from
the sec but from like one person at the
sec in 2018 said they thought that
ethereum was like far enough along that
it's more or less decentralized now yeah
even michael
mentioned that to me sailor yeah maybe
we'll see anyway i don't think they're
going to go back and do anything about
it now but a lot of these other ones you
know have to
you know essentially pay play a lot of
legal jiu-jitsu
to set up how they uh you know
essentially launch these tokens and you
can't just sort of create these things
that benefit
from the efforts of a centralized group
where the investors
and the team that found it uh profit
from their collective endeavors which is
the definition of the security so you
gotta be really really careful with that
um i think the so one argument is
basically that
none of these non-bitcoin blockchains
are decentralized enough to withstand
uh you know state pressure and they're
just not um
not really useful for anything other
than being slow
uh relatively you know
semi-decentralized but really in the end
still centralized databases so
blockchain technology is
decades old and is is slow and is
expensive and you'd be better off for
almost all of these use cases just
running it on aws
or some other kind of you know database
system
um let me give kind of a
maybe like an economic argument as well
like the addressable market for
for money for store value that bitcoin
is going after
is you know sort of on the low end let's
call it like 200 trillion dollars and
this is just in terms of of today's
market for store value this does not end
in real dollars by the way not nominal
dollars
and aggressively like 400 trillion
dollars uh
everything else you can call it like
smart contracts you could call it
fintech you could call it like making it
easier to sort of like
create you know coalitions or
cooperation or
consortia or whatever it is like all of
that
stuff uh just has
you know a potential market cap of
orders of magnitude less
and these things are all unproven and
are essentially
at best you know maybe like early stage
venture bets that are way overpriced
and at worst as we've seen over and over
and over again outright scams
so that's kind of the the main argument
against
all coins you know the place that i'd
say like
fine whatever is like if you're a
professional trader
and you were before you got into crypto
and you're very successful at it and you
have great tools and you're not what
uh real traders would derogative
derogatorily call a click trader which
means somebody that actually used their
hands
and essentially you're using algorithms
things like that like sure
it's it's a great way to make money
hopefully you store your profits in
bitcoin
all of my friends that are traders in
this space many of whom are
very well known and i talk to you know
if not daily at least a couple times a
week
um you know their long-term stocks their
long-term store of value is in bitcoin
and their denominator their goal
their base money is bitcoin and the
return the rate of return
that they're measuring themselves
against and trying to beat
is bitcoin so even the best altcoin
traders
are already using bitcoin not only as a
store of value
not only as a medium exchange but also
as their unit of account
and that's the people who know all coins
the best and they're already choosing
bitcoin
as the money and uh just um
you know not germaine to um to bitcoin
specifically but they're
just from a technologist's point of view
do they have
are there interesting uses of blockchain
uh we've heard about these what are they
called nfts or nfgs or something like
that uh
non-fungible things we've heard about
bitcoin yeah that's blockchain the
latest
yeah it's non non-fungible tokens is
basically the latest
narrative coming out of ethereum which
is kind of like requires a new narrative
to spin up every year or two
to keep the long-running scam going um
so the latest one is nfts they've
actually been around for a while there
were
companies founded around this you know
back in 2016 2017.
they have i think it's erst 721 if i
recall
is sort of the non-fungible like unique
digital object
token thing whatever um
you know i don't have any
i don't it's it's a hard one because i
actually had there are bitcoiners that
want to see nfts
on bitcoin and then there are some i'm
just now paying a little bit of
attention because you kind of have to
because people ask about it a lot
uh there's a very strong argument that
you can never ever
bring uh any sort of like valuable
ownership
of anything offline you know or
art let's say uh onto a decentralized a
truly decentralized blockchain
i'm just not deep enough into it to say
that
what i do know is that let's say that
those problems get solved
and i did want to buy unique digital art
or unique digital objects
i would never in a million years buy one
that was secured by anything other than
the bitcoin blockchain because i'd have
absolutely no confidence that i would be
able to pass it along to my heirs or
have it
you know be worth anything in 34 years
or whatever
yeah so that does ethereum is just not
secure
and it was the subject of some kind of a
attack as i remember
not too long ago but that brings me to
another one of nicolas taleb's
famous theses what i love about nicholas
teleb is that you can get uh almost the
entire
value of the book just from the title so
we talked about the black swan
influenced swan bitcoin there's another
one that's influencing
keating coin which is uh which is called
anti-fragility
uh which i'm going to make fragile coin
no i'm not going to do that i'm just
joking corey
but uh there is this notion of something
is anti-fragile if it actually
benefits from stress and i see and i
mentioned this to peter you know because
the argument is and now you're going to
take up this side of the argument
bitcoin's only been around since 2009
it hasn't seen true you know super
cycles in the market
how can you put so much trust in it and
i told peter it's been through at least
a few barred bowl cycles when i became
aware of it
uh in 2017 you know it was 3 000 then it
went to about 17 000 then it went back
down to 3 000 then it went up
so it's been through many cycles does
that not count as an anti-fragility
encounter that bitcoin comes out
victorious or
am i wrong i mean that is definitely
like in the pro column i think looking
at
network incentives and looking at the
the different players and the way that
they've reacted to different
stressors from the outside i think kind
of shows
shows the game theory of of the network
and the system and how the players you
know what their incentives are and how
they
how they should do it right so you even
saw uh
that the users the people actually
running nodes
had more power than the miners
when the miners tried to fork off right
and and tried to push through
uh you know the nya agreement and and
basically double the block size and
that's what caused the split with uh
bitcoin cash and bitcoin sv and however
many more of those have forked into now
um and so that was the user activated
softwork
and essentially putting putting through
you know a pure
more decentralized version of bitcoin
and the users actually had that
incentive and that incentive
to protect bitcoin has been there from
the very beginning and it's actually not
all that hard in retrospect it was very
heated at the time
but it wasn't all that hard if you think
about it it didn't it didn't involve
you know tons of uh you know major
strife major spending none of that it
really was just education
and you know some social media and a lot
of you know podcasts and writing
that marshalled these people to see the
truth and to win the day
in the favor of of keeping bitcoin
intact
as opposed to going off in the wrong
direction so i love that that just keeps
on
happening and then when you see you know
i think the anti-fragility is
is basically you know he talks about
probably the dividing line between you
know fragile or robust
and anti-fragile is whether something is
alive or not
and that's when it's kind of fun to look
at bitcoin and to say like
wow this thing really exhibits the
characteristics of something that is
alive it may be the first truly alive
thing that we as humans have actually
created
uh that didn't come from life before
like we've cloned things and we've made
things out of bacteria or whatever
all the stuff that your friends across
in the in the building next door
have figured out in the bio department
or whatever but you know this is
something that actually is alive and
that none of us can do anything about it
you know and in that respect you know
this this
should and it is attracting a lot of the
singularity folks now because they're
realizing that
you know this thing this thing lives and
we all kind of work
for it and adjust to it and bitcoin
changes you you don't change bitcoin
so that brings me to my final question
before we move on to clubhouse
uh solely onto clubhouse from the
remaining half an hour or so that i have
and that's a question i asked peter and
i asked many of the colleagues who
graced me by coming on the into the
impossible podcast ranging from
nine nobel laureates four billionaires i
don't know you might be the fifth uh who
knows corey
uh you're not saying uh but the uh the
people that come on oftentimes they have
uh
sort of an opportunity to talk their
book in other words they're
going to promote something which may or
may not be proven
we hear this a lot i was tweeting today
about all these references to god that
physicists make who
are predominantly atheist and it's kind
of interesting to me that they invoke
the name of god
in order to justify some of the claims
that god has attracted around him
or it or whatever you want to say about
this supernatural force of nature if it
does indeed exist anyway
one of the foremost exponents of that
was stephen hawking who wrote one of the
most popular popular science books in
all time called the brief history of
time
the very end of that book he references
god but the point of that book is to
dispel
the need for god via these theories that
he came up with which i won't get into
in this conversation i
talk about it quite frequently in my
podcast and i view that as an example of
confirmation bias
that he so wanted to disprove the
existence of god for whatever reasons
maybe he was angry maybe he loved god i
don't know
i don't care but i wonder to what extent
can your belief credulity in bitcoin be
shaken is there anything
that could uh falsify the bullish
hypothesis that you support or is it
intrinsically unfalsifiable
i mean i guess it would only be the
facts on the ground
which would really be like bitcoin going
to zero and nobody buying yet
but you know that that
so many people so much smarter than i am
for the last 12 years have spent
so many thousands tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of hours
collectively
thinking of every potential threat and
either
figuring out why it's not a worry or
actively working to mitigate the threat
and working on bitcoin to make it
stronger this is not something that is
static
this is something that develops over
time that you know
takes all of the best developments from
outside and if it fits then they bring
it in
they look at every potential threat as
they identify it they change bitcoin to
make it stronger
and you know it's uh
it's really hard to to i mean
by definition any any threat that is uh
a worry to bitcoin at this point lives
in the fourth quadrant
it's an unknown unknown we already know
and have mitigated collectively me not
personally any probably but
i've been working hard on mitigating the
threat of like any sort of government
action
against bitcoiners at least in the
united states that's kind of
the one thing that i work hard on um and
i just think that chance is now
vanishingly small given what's happened
over the last year
um but uh yeah i can't
think of something none of us really can
think of a reason
and that's why these you know the
the credible fudsters don't really exist
anymore
it's just kind of like a clown's gallery
that are marketing their own thing
you know it's just people trying to stay
in the spotlight whether it's peter
tweeting about bitcoin between five and
eight times a day on average
um when he's supposed to be selling gold
but doesn't have a leg to stand on
or it's muriel or beanie like trying to
stay relevant when he's just a disaster
or it's you know one of my favorite
authors thinkers
philosophers probably my favorite in all
three
uh tele but you know he's got a personal
beef with
somebody who wrote a bitcoin book and
decides to take that out personally
on bitcoin and you know he doesn't sound
like the telev that we know and love
from his books
when he tries to trot out these worries
about bitcoin or these attacks on
bitcoin and bitcoiners
he just sounds like some dude at the bar
that's had too many unfortunately
um i don't think that'll last i think
eventually like when he sits down
and and thinks about things like he
usually thinks them through and
generally ends up correct i think that's
that will happen with michael bury
that will happen with taleb and i think
the only people you'll be left with are
the people that
have businesses to market and need free
media
essentially to market their businesses
and those will be the only people left
arguing against bitcoin and it's a
vanishingly small number of people and
there's no one credible doing that
anymore
let me ask you one final question i know
i said i already asked you one question
but
what would it take for you to sell your
bitcoin or
you know and what what what regime what
kind of scenario
can you envision oh just not not having
any not having anything else to sell
like if i didn't have anything else to
spend that's when you that's when you
sell bitcoin is when you don't have
anything else to spend
and even then it's starting to look like
you could probably do what you know the
owners of manhattan apartment buildings
do or what
nfl franchise owners do which is you
basically just take out super cheap
loans secured by
an appreciating asset and you
essentially like rack up debt for the
rest of your life and you never ever
ever sell the asset
so it's very possible that all these
people that are buying bitcoin today
will never ever ever ever sell
yeah maybe last question the last last
question
of this stream uh so normally with an
asset that you know i
if i had some insider tip and i had true
conviction in bitcoin which i don't but
if i
did i wouldn't be telling you to buy it
i'd be buying it all myself or
buying as much as i can and to what
extent you know does does that
contribute to this perception
that there is such a such a very very
passionate group of people who are
working extremely hard
do you feel that you know people look at
uh
look at it and say well why are you
promoting this is it is it to benefit
people
is it circling back to the very
beginning of our conversation
what is your mission i asked michael he
says he wants to educate a million minds
you as i said earlier our teacher in
addition to whatever success you have as
an
investor or as you know as an exponent
and uh and owner of a business but
where do you see it going what are you
going to use this wealth for i asked
peter i asked
michael saylor what is the purpose of
wealth to you corey clemson
i mean beyond sort of like meeting basic
needs of my family
i think you know at this point i'm just
so fully
immersed in trying to make bitcoin
happen and happen
you know as soon as possible and spread
as far and as wide as possible
and i don't think that we know what the
new problems are going to be
we can we're thinking them through and
having lots of conversations about what
a bitcoin eyes or post
hyperbitcoinization world
looks like and also what opportunities
there will be
when you have fair money that's global
and you know essentially a friction free
uh global economy and all the
productivity that gets unlocked by that
where we see something along the lines
of you know essentially like a
deflationary economy that's much more
equity based and
kind of the getting rid of debt you'll
either have zero debt you'll have like
90
less than you do today something like
that all those global debt markets will
shrink
so so many things will change and so
many things will inherently get
better in a bitcoin eyes world that
i have a lot of trouble working on
anything else
other than this right now because
i think this is the most important thing
going on in the world today
so i'm pretty much just like focused on
like my family my friends
you know maybe donating here and there
to you know people's causes when it
comes to my
attention but otherwise focused
completely both personally and
professionally on bitcoin
i think it's really important to note
that i would say
95 of the people that i know working in
bitcoin
uh were hardcore bitcoiners first before
starting to work in bitcoin
they don't start working in bitcoin
and then develop like this you know
roster of arguments in favor of bitcoin
that has causation completely ass
backwards
and is the type of thing that you would
get when a marketer
with a poor product is projecting their
own motivations
onto another group of people so when you
hear all coiners saying that bitcoiners
are trying to run a ponzi or that you
know well they're only in it because of
their bitcoin bags or you see gold bugs
you know trying to project something on
the bitcoiners as they try to show their
bags their gold bags
they're completely missing out that
almost everybody working bitcoin can't
work on anything else
because this is what they really really
truly care about and they cared about it
long before they started working on it
well corey i want to thank you so much
for going into the impossible and
educating my listeners who don't usually
get to hear although lately
i have to admit i've been having a lot
of fun talking about it but um
maybe we'll talk someday about the
scientific applications of this and i
want to point out that thanks to corey
and thanks to me bitcoin is now fifty
thousand dollars
six fifty thousand six hundred and
twenty dollars at least according to my
iphone
anyway corey i wanna thank you so much
now we're gonna move over to clubhouse
exclusively
so i ask uh my indulgences upon my
listeners who don't happen to have
access to clubhouse
i wish we could give those invites to
you but as with bitcoin
it's limited in supply uh but by the
logarithm of the amount of bitcoins that
exist corey thank you so much for going
into the impossible
yes my pleasure see you soon see you in
a minute see you on clubhouse